hello everyone
my name is may basaron i'm a software
engineer i'm an infant developer at
forder i write in groovy python closure
node.js and several other languages
um on a daily basis i am a mentor and a
public speaker
and yes i must learn star wars fan you
can see that in the presentation you can
see that in my background
you know i don't think you can miss that
so
i already did uh quite a few closure
talks in my life and
most of the talks that i did were about
some
uh game development uh or maybe just
functional programming in general
or you know there were many uh different
talks that i did
and about closure and i think that the
uh the main thing was
that i showed is just a single player
game
and then somebody that i talked with
just approached to me
and he said
well closure is nice but if you ever
decide to write a multiplayer online
game well you can't do that in closure
and
you know what happens when you tell a
developer that they can't do something
i'm in
so
um
yeah i decided i am going to write
a multiplayer online game enclosure
and i'm going to do that in under 100
lines of code or at least the backend
will be under 100 lines of code and
that's the game that we're going to
check out today
so
the
uh the back end of the game is written
in closure as i mentioned
and the front end is written in react js
and it was written by my friend rohi
thank you rui for that
so now let's check out the game itself
so what you can see over here
uh is the way the game starts you can
see that we have two windows opened and
you can see that uh the way that you
know that you are the player is if
you're a monkey with a little crown on
your head then this is how you know that
you are the self
um i see that a few more people joined
so just for the sake of those who just
recently joined i'm gonna tell you that
the game that you see right now uh the
beckon is written in closure and the
front end is written in react.js and it
just it's just monkeys uh scattered
around the screen and what these monkeys
are trying to do
is now we have just one screen and not a
split screen so it will be easier for
everyone to see but you can see the
other players over here um
so every monkey has uh their you know
his own exception of baba's head
exception type so for instance the one
that you see right now has a divide by
your zero exception um
and you can only collect exceptions that
match the one that you have on your head
the idea
was
you know enclosure exceptions are kind
of annoying and it's hard to understand
what's going on them with them so i was
like oh what if every person can collect
their own
um
you know exceptions i don't know i
thought it was funny at the time i hope
you guys are laughing and girls are
laughing somewhere
uh and if not you know i'm laughing for
you
okay so that's the game i want you to
notice that uh we have um a player
that goes around the screen each each
person over here like i said wants to
collect uh exceptions but please
remember that you can totally do that
with any other things it doesn't have to
be exceptions you can define your own
player that will be maybe i don't know
collect bananas or apples
that's the idea of of this game that
it's uh quite simple
but still has enough complications in
order for us to be able to talk about
the challenges and choices that i had to
make when i worked on this game so let
me talk about uh
all of these challenges and choices uh
in you know two steps the first thing
that i'm going to talk about is only the
challenges i want to describe
what were the challenges for me when i
decided to develop
a multiplayer online game
and
then i will tell you about the choices
that i made
in order to handle these challenges now
when i will go through these challenges
i want you to try to think uh with
yourself how would you do that and then
later at the q a session i would be so
happy if some of you will uh you know
step up and participate and tell me how
would you do things uh if you do it the
same like i did if you've already
developed
multiplayer online game share those
thoughts with me and let's do it
together
so the first challenge is to define the
game flow what does it mean you know in
general you want to define the game that
you're going to develop
so you want to define the amount of
players you want to define the movement
can you move in 2d in two directions
just left and right or maybe you know up
and down only or can you move in four
directions like just like you saw that
our monkeys can go um also you want to
decide about the boundaries
um can you leave the window just like in
snake um where if the snakes leave the
window then he can come back from the
other side you know um
or you can't live the window this is how
i did it with the monkeys game monkey
when he reached the end of the window he
can't leave it
um and then another thing that you want
to remember is you want to handle
collisions how do you do that if you
want to be able to collide with other
players if you want that if you had a
collision with an item do you want to
collect it do you want to ignore it and
of course you want to decide if there
are winner
winner situation or losing situation
that's it
so the next thing that we want to do is
to choose the game architecture there
are several popular ways to define the
game architecture and you got to think
about both the internal architecture and
also
about the communication
between server and you know between
clients and server and
there is no one right way to do that
remember that even the biggest gaming
companies are still facing this matter
today the communication part and try to
make it you know the fastest the best
the easiest so
you know
then that what we need to do is to
define not just the communication
between the client server but we also
want to define the protocol now what
does it mean to define the protocol we
want to define
um
what will be sent in the messages
between
the client and the server do you plan to
send only you know just specific limited
information from the server to the
client um
what about you know all of the images
and graphical things where do you hold
these so this is
also some of the things that you'll have
to consider when i say protocol you know
how do you
how do a client recognize uh self you
know if we have so many players how does
the client recognize if a player is self
rather than just other players stuff
like that
will be a part of the decisions that
you'll have to make
i think one of the last things is
managing the game state
and what is a game state anyway let me
talk about that for a minute so
a game state is the mode of the game
entities at a given time for example the
location of the players the number of
players uh the number of items to
collect etc so that's what it means to
have to handle the game state you want
to decide uh who determines the game
state probably the smartest would be to
have the server do that
in order to maintain consistency because
if you know if you have one player
deciding on the game state then uh you
know it might cause a few consistency
problems if you do that uh in a
different way but
there are architectures
that have been doing that over the years
so i can't say
uh
that it's completely wrong right
um okay
a part of you know part of the things
that you'll have to handle will be
adding a new player handling player
movement what happens when the player
has left the game and then handling the
player entities which means what happens
to all the things that are scattered
around the screen which is not the
player
so we talked about the challenges and
now i'm going to talk about the choices
that i made
um i
the first thing that i uh you know i
mentioned was the game flow so you know
if i make it as into a simpler mode then
you can see that this is actually
the game flow that we have
so we have several different players and
each player can move in four directions
and
they can all collect uh items that match
their something so over here i showed it
with simply every player can collect an
item that match the color of you know
their little head
um notice that i defined that there will
be no obstacles it means it means that
the player can move freely uh not like
in pacman and pacman there are not
obstacles but there is like a maze so
that was also something that i decided
to do not to have a maze not to have
obstacles but it doesn't mean that i
won't edit in the next um you know
version of this game by the way i don't
think i mentioned it but this is why
this talk is called attack of the clones
uh too that's because this stock is a
part of a series of a talk that i do uh
every time that i do the stock it's
where when i develop the game a bit
further and i show it so
you know try to check it out or or you
know find the next talk that i do
if you're interested in seeing the next
version of this monkey game okay that
was a side note i'm going back to talk
about the main thing
i was talking about the game flow uh
let's move forward
so
now that we we're done with the game
flow i'll tell you about the
architecture that i chose
so
i chose the client server architecture
which means
that there is one server who determines
what you know the game state and he
sends it to all of the connected clients
this also means that
if one player um yeah
notice how it's
ugly
ugly um arrows i know
i i chose to to to leave those arrows
because i thought oh well they'll know
that i am
incapable of drawing so it's okay right
so what we see over here with my ugly
arrows in the screen
is how it goes uh with the architecture
that i chose like what's happening there
we need that if player one made a move
you know it will be sent to the server
it does not determine the new
coordinates of the player what will be
sent to the server is only
the
fact that the player moved somewhere and
how you know maybe if you moved a little
bit if he moved further but that's
what's going to be sent to the server
and so the client will inform the server
about that move then the server will
calculate the new coordination of the
player and he will uh send these
coordinates to all of the connected
player
now
um you you can see that right in the
drawing that he sends to player two and
to player three hey player one made
moved left hey player three
player one move left um actually an
arrow that i now see that i forgot to
add is how the server also
sends these coordinates to player one
itself
so that's missing in the drawing but i
just told you about that
okay
now we do we will talk about defining
the communication and protocols between
the
uh client and server so messages
protocol
this uh what you see over here is
actually
uh the first message on the left that is
sent from the client to the server on
you know on the moment of the connection
so
what will be sent is just this tiny json
and you can see that it's already
actually written in a map style
enclosure but it's just a json that's
coming from the client side and this
json will only have
uh height and width of the window
and
we want to send that to the server so
then the server will be able to
determine where he will locate you know
the first you know the player position
and all of the things that he has to
send back to the client that are based
on the side the size of the window
so now we have on the second message
this is the message that the server will
send to the client back once he knows
that a client has
connected
so
let's go over this map i want you to get
familiar with it because we're going to
use it uh throughout the session um we
have the first key
says self question mark true
now i want you to notice that it also
says player question mark true and then
we have the id key
so all of these three keys they say this
first of all
this map describes a player second of
all second of all this player is also
self you know this is the one uh that
this is the one monkey that needs to
have the crown on the head
okay and we also sent an id now you can
see that it's just a randomly generated
uuid
um and because we wanted it to be unique
and this is how
i determine uh which player is which and
i make sure that everyone is not someone
else
and
then the rest of the keys that we have
over here x y that's location score you
know that's how much how many um
exceptions you've collected we also have
show true which determines if this
player is connected or not
and then we have exception type this is
what will determine what's written above
the player's head
we have collision false
and this is where i decided to
determine what happens when somebody
collide with the with the window uh if
it says collision true
this is how you know i handle
the collisions part you'll see that in a
little bit and window height and window
width
uh this is these values always change
in case the client change them uh
because we always want them to batch
what we have in the client side
okay
now
we we just saw okay i'll go back just
for a minute we just saw these messages
this is how
um
this is how it starts okay the
communication between the client and the
server now throughout the game what's
going on here is that the client only
sends use uh what you see over there
client to service sends x plus 10 plus
10 it means you know the movement that
was there and then
the server will send i'm sorry my phone
was lost on quiet mode okay so
and then the server will send a message
uh with the updated game state and you
can see over here the player map that we
already discussed and also another map
is exception question mark true uh these
are the exceptions that are scattered
around
the screen
okay
now the way that i did the communication
was using websockets i'm not gonna talk
too much about web sockets but this is
how it's usually done the first thing
will be an http request from the client
to the server and then it will be an
upgrade by the server to a
bi-directional open communication open
and persistent until
one of the sides closes the channel
that's pretty much it there is a lot
more to say about websockets which i'm
not going to do today but
i will tell you that i used the http kit
library enclosure now let's see how to
use that library what you can see over
here and now listen even if you've never
written enclosure i just want you to
focus on the names of the functions that
you see over here
defend means defining a function and you
can see that we have defend websocket
handler
and this means that this is where we're
handling the requests uh after the
connection is open between the client
and the server we have deaf websocket
routes remember how i told you that
websocket starts with an http request it
happens right there you see get and then
uh the backslash that's it
and then we have in the main it says run
server and it's uh websocket routes it's
called the websocket routes that i
defined
up there and that's it so i'll go back
now i want to go back to the
uh websocket handler uh
function that you see over here what we
get is a request
and you can see that it says on close
channel which is saying what happens
when the connection is closed well if
the connection is closed what you want
to do is call the remove player function
and on receive this is what will
actually happen as long as the
connection is open we want to call the
process message function
now here's the process message function
this function has two modes either
adding a new player
or
updating the player state
these are the two modes right because
if uh if a player has just uh was just
added then i want to do some things and
then it's a whole different thing if i
want to update and you can see that what
they they're both getting over here is
the height and width of the um of the
window and also the specific connection
and this is how i can tell which
connection i am currently working on
uh in terms of processing the data that
i got
now
i'll briefly talk about how i handled
the active connections uh you can see
that i have uh an atom which is with a
list in it
and it's or you know in closure it's not
really a list i can call it just
collection
so i have a players collection
and what it means is
all what i will have there is all of the
active players are going to be
added to this collection
each player is represented as a map and
we already saw the map of
a player you can see that again over
here this is actually where i create a
new player you can see that uh do you
remember that i said that we have player
a question mark true this is how we know
that this map represents a player and
not something else
so
we will have many maps like that that
each map describes a different player
how do we know that this map describes a
different player that's because we have
the id key just like we have over here
um okay let's move forward
now what we want to do is when the
server got a message i talked about how
the thing that the server wants to do is
to either add a new player or update uh
an existing player another thing is
the play the then the server wants to
update uh the other connections about
what just happened right
so we have two functions for that
just check it out
you we have the send message function
send message function gets two things as
an input
we get con which is a short for
connection and we have message so it
means that this function gets the
connection that we want to send
the message to and the message to be
sent
you can see that i used the send um
function over here this is actually a
function that is uh from the http kit um
library so send
this message to this connection that's
it look how short and cute this is i
mean
it's insane i don't know i love it
um
then we call this function the send
message function we call it from
broadcast message
now what broadca broadcast message
function is doing it receives a message
and then you can see that i called dusek
what doucek is doing it actually goes
through
all of the players list or collection
and it sends the same message
to all of the connections and then
that's it
so
this is how
the server
updates the current game state to all of
the
um to all of the
uh connections and then that's it
all right let's move forward
um
now we need to manage the game state
okay
um
when i talked about managing the game
state i told you that we want to handle
adding a new player player movement uh
what happens when the player has left
the game
uh and let's see that
so
um
how do we add a new player adding a new
player means that first of all we want
to send a message to uh to the player
himself
the one that actually
uh you know created this message
happening
um you see that i did the self true over
here
so that's what we have uh on the first
line in this function then we have two
calls to do sec why do we why do i do
that so for the first one is because i
want to send um the
all of the existing players
to um to the new player right because
let's say i just joined the game and
there are already five or you know maybe
three
players over there then i need to
iterate over all of the all of these
players and send all of them to
me the new one and then i want to go
ahead and send to all of them
the new player right i wanna update all
other players that a new player joined
um
and then uh that's it i want to
uh update the players list that's the
last thing that i do with adding the new
connection in
all right
now
we will talk about the player movement
all right what do we have over here now
every time that i call the update player
state um function
i have um i've been sending the
connection and also the new x and new y
into this uh function
now the updating
of the
new uh values is being done in a
different function it's just a very
small function that calculates um the
previous x plus 10
equals the new x so i didn't put that in
here and so we get those new values
and then we have the move player
um
we have the move player function and
then we do the
collect because what happens in the
collect function is i check whether i
need to
collect some of those exceptions that
were scattered around the screen and
last i am going to send uh i'm going to
broadcast the message
to um
all of the connected players that's it
okay let's move forward
um
player movement uh you saw how i called
the collect um
function before now i don't think that i
want to go into this function i just
wanted to show you that what we're doing
over here is we gotta make sure
that if an item was collected
then i wanna remove it from the items
map i wanna update the player uh
new score in the players map and i need
to return the updated player to
the uh player himself
okay
now what happens if a player left the
game um we just need to remove him
from the
list of all players
and
that's pretty much it you know we've
been going through all of those things
and we are done
now
what you see over here
is um
we have
the
original drawing that i
used for the game you can see it's not
as nice as what i had in at the end
right
so
um
i i want to do a quick summary of what
we talked about today before i finish
and then we can do the q a session um
all right
so
we talked about the different choices
and challenges that you have to make
when you develop a multiplayer online
game
i told you that
there is more than one way to do things
and for me i went with the simplest way
that i found at that moment because it
was important for me to be able to
finish that game because sometimes it's
super hard to finish side projects um
so i start simple and then i upgrade it
and
i hope that next time you'll join me
when i'll do the next talk
and
that's it let me know if you have any
questions
thank you
i see that there are some questions in
the chat and stuff like that i hope you
enjoyed you know i can't see any of the
participants but
i do hope you enjoyed this talk so thank
you so much